We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. speaking of people misunderstanding
what I say, here's someone who asks, why am
I a centrist Neo liberal shill?
Hey David.
Um, I just wanted to know why are you supporting,
uh, Jordan Peterson by supporting his right
wing network or whatever the book is called?
Why are you such a centrist neoliberal show?
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
So listen, I addressed the thing.
Think of spot thing yesterday.
I'm not going to do it again.
Um, I have taken every, uh, political spectrum
and compass test that anybody has sent me.
I am more to the left than I have ever been
before.
Over the last 10 years.
I've taken those tests many times on the David
Pakman show and every single time I end up
further to the left.
So, uh, that's me pretending to take the voicemail
seriously.
We've got a great bonus show today.
Russia has been banned from the Olympics and
global sports for four years over doping,
former white house physician, Ronnie Jackson
is going to run for Congress, and there's
an interesting bill in the house, which could
lower patient's prescription drug spending
significantly.
And we will talk about that and much more
on the bonus show.
Get access to the bonus show by becoming a
member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomingapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.